well a belated congratulations on the
engagement
yeah there's the ring
it's so big it turns around all the time
i have to wear a band to try and keep it
in place
well i feel like uh come a wedding day a
band will come that will uh yeah we'll
get it out
for the wedding next year we'll add a
band on top and then i'll just be
blinged out because this isn't enough
you know yeah you can't see that at all
i i
it's just i don't know what it is about
you but it's like people will not let
you be happy
the ring comes out you're like well it's
not a diamond i'm like can we let this
girl
live yeah my my daughter's birthstone is
a diamond we're gonna be buying them for
the rest of our life i've already had a
diamond i didn't need a diamond nor did
i want one i love morganized stones and
this one it's exactly what i wanted so i
don't care what anyone else thinks about
it because it's it's bigger than what i
wanted i will say that but
i think it was bigger i wanted to
hey i've got this great stone it's just
a little bit bigger than what you said i
was like
i said eight carrots he said nine to ten
kyle's like how about almost 13.
will we get to see the engagement on the
show or is that a private off-camera
moment
unless they cut it okay it was filmed
okay
it was filmed you guys will see there's
this intimate moment between me and
sheena that we had in our place with a
full camera crew with vocabulary
in as intimate as reality
i want to unpack that but i have a
couple more engagement wedding questions
before we get into the show will you
wear another crop top wedding dress he
asked me that too i
i don't
think so
why not he made it iconic didn't he yeah
but i already did it you want me to
repeat what i did the first time we
could just do it better i could do it
better so that's the
crop top pearl crop top two-piece
wedding dress
that is the ugliest effing wedding dress
i've ever seen in my entire life if you
want me to get married in a crop top
honey i will get married again
perfect
sheena you were one of my last in-person
interviews before the world shut down he
wants nothing to do with the show
your intention was to keep brock away
from these cameras to not
have him become as integrated as a
casper as he is in season nine
other than the world changing how did
you come to this decision that like this
was the right move to make i believe
that if this was 2020 and we started
filming in may like we normally did i
wasn't ready to put a six-month
relationship on national television i
learned my lesson with brock i mean
[Laughter]
freudian slip
at least it was that way around right
i just putting that relationship on the
show so soon
i didn't want to do that again and brock
what kind of convincing did it take for
you to say yes was it an immediate yes
or did sheena have to put in a little
work to get you to this
it wasn't it was just i was all
supportive of sheena like when it came
time the year and a half later i was
like yeah babe i've got your back let's
put our best foot forward because it's
such a great platform he didn't have to
twist my arm too hard to do it with her
but it was definitely a learning
experience but i kind of i think i did
the right thing what surprised you about
the experience because it's one thing to
hear sheena talk about it it's one thing
to watch the edited episodes come out
it's a whole other thing
to see
we're still in we just filmed but now i
get to see the edits come out so that's
what i look forward to seeing but hey
you know what it was good he also
learned the hard way that anything you
say off camera to a cast member will
then be brought up on camera so
yes
reality tv rule number one there are no
secrets to be kept this season on the
vanderpump rules
when the trailer came out did your
stomach drop or was it like oh a relief
because now it's out in the world well
that's the thing it's obviously
it goes personal with me with my family
especially my ex and my kids and so
that's something that's going to come
back and that's going to be an issue to
deal with brock has two kids he hasn't
spoken to them in four years cena gave
me some pointers and i didn't listen to
any of her advice at all
and uh i just did a did it how i thought
it would be the best version that was
tell my story so i did that um and
through the season you'll get to see
that um
but yeah when it came out i was like
here we go like but you know what we've
all got past and you guys will you guys
will hear about mine and get to know me
so
regardless someone's going to have an
opinion so good honestly
yeah what you're referencing there is
this moment that we've seen in the
trailer of la la saying that you have
not spoken to your children in years
which i i assume we're gonna get your
side of the story and your response to
that but what do you want people to know
now headed into the season anything you
want to
clear the air about yeah i think uh the
biggest one is just like these are kids
we're talking about here right so
the fact that it's even a conversation
shouldn't be a conversation there should
be a rule when kids are involved you
don't bring kids into it so if you're
low enough to bring kids into it then do
you boo-boo
do you boo-boo okay
there is
speculation slash rumor this is the
other thing you're gonna get used to as
all the fan accounts having thoughts
opinions feelings and assumptions about
you um but one of the pre-season ones is
that you fill the jack's tailor-sized
hole on this cast and maybe cause a
little
you'll take it okay
i would take that because i know for a
fact that even even talking to the old
cast like there was definitely a
different vibe this season these are
nine years of friendships
where they've really been tested and now
they're trying to grow and involve as
individuals and that's where my aspect
comes in and so i really enjoy that
especially this season so if that meant
being confronting somebody about some
things that's because we have strong
opinions and i think that kind of comes
across this season real quick
you said the the evolution of the show
this is a different vibe it is in the
premiere we're breaking the fourth wall
and doing the thing the hills never did
which was a dress but you guys have
become famous there is a world outside
of the show
the first episode in the first episode
we are talking about podcasts and saying
things on podcasts and you know moments
finally my podcast is mentioned yes
getting to
bring those parts of your world and
address this reality you live in on
reality tv is that exciting to you
now that to finally get to do it
yeah i feel like long time coming it's
unfortunate the reason why
it's mentioned is because i opened my
mouth instead of picking up a phone and
calling a friend it's really exciting to
just
see
us working on real things then fighting
over which table you're going to take in
the restaurant and whose birthday are
you going to go to because they have the
same birthday and it just it's a lot
deeper this season it's very real i
think
and you don't lose a sense of what you
guys were which was a group of kids that
wanted want to grow up right but you
still have the influence of lisa around
lisa is a big influence even on me she's
a huge influence then and you do get to
see a bit more of the real stuff because
you can't hide that anymore and i think
for those of us who have been on the
show for so long when you take the
restaurant aspect away from us you
really get a deeper dive into us that i
don't think you've ever really seen on
the show so do you not pick up a single
shift at sir this season not
one
new bartender right here
i i did want to get on the bar and just
as good as gold but
i missed my opportunity always season
10.
[Music]
turn down a good as gold live
performance
um
you mentioned this drama with lala um
sheena
just
invited me to a birthday party
are you gonna bring lala
have you spoken to her about it at all
like with lala in the whole situation
i don't think
she understands how upsetting that was
that she wasn't there for me during my
miscarriage because she had dinner with
celebrities so you'll see
a lot of that
play out and then she comes for him
then that's a whole other issue so i'm
like i don't come for your man i
protected that relationship when her and
i first met so
for her to not do the same for me
you will see
that play out okay so we're like going
on an upward trajectory she makes these
console brock it goes down but i can
only assume it's gone back up because
we've seen that ocean and summer have
hung out together and lala even told me
last time i spoke to her that she
doesn't think she could have done this
season without you because you were the
only person who understood exactly the
feeling she was going through as a new
mom filming a show same it helped so
much having that support having someone
else who's been through the exact same
thing it definitely definitely added to
you guys friendship too rebuilding that
friendship it was rebuilt on a different
bond this time yeah and we want our
daughters to grow up being friends you
know we don't want our petty issues to
hold back them from being friends
eventually i mean they're already
friends they just don't know it yet
really they don't know it yet yeah um we
see in the trailer you get emotional i
like want to go home to my baby i don't
even want to be here anymore what is the
biggest difference between filming not
as a mom and filming as a mom let me
just say if i ever get invited to
another tea party i will not be going
not one but two explosive tea parties
this season and like few parties
when there is like this petty drama of
like you haven't been there for me
that's the exact situation that happened
with one of the girls was like well you
haven't been here for me and i'm like
because i had a baby so like i just
wanted at that moment i'm like why am i
sitting here eating a macaroon and
sipping tea i want to go home to my baby
this is like
such
and uh but
welcome to our friend group you know
well now i feel like summer is probably
becoming a little person like a little
human you want to see her
yeah
do you ever look at her like i popped
out myself yes she looks exactly like
you look exactly like me like when i was
a baby oh my gosh
sometimes i just swear oh my god that
was me as a baby look right there
look at you
she's already a pro she's got oh and she
says i'm over it no fame no questions
[Laughter]
she's been pretty good at keeping her
mouth shut you know or like don't know
gotta say stay tuned
summer moon honey my little angel you
know not all babies are as cute as you
getting back to the drama of season 9 it
seems that lala is the ultimate potster
this season true or false
sure we also see her and ariana
starting off the season
on maybe the worst foot of all did that
surprise you that they were
in it in that way and it seems to not
get any better over the course of the
season no because ariana really had my
back and knew every
detail of the situation that happened
and she just wasn't standing for it so
it was like sure sheena you can make up
with her but like i haven't forgot
everything and then
the day
of my birthday party that morning a
podcast comes out of lala trashing
ariana saying i don't give a [ __ ] about
you you don't care about me like why are
we pretending and ariana's like i
actually did give up about you until now
so
that was like her own issues with her on
top of how she treated me i'll teach you
how to be cool later [ __ ] babe i was
born pretty cool who disappointed you
the most
lala
just because because of the brock thing
or more yeah i just it was something
that as a stepmom with you know two kids
who were left off the show
i just was hoping that she would have
that same respect for brock
as we all have for randall so
that was definitely very disappointing i
think that's a good point you just made
of that's the respect everyone has for
randall and his children who are not on
the show yeah it was just kind of like a
double standard there and
it was like just because brock you know
signed up for this kids should still be
off limits and we respect that so why
don't you and that was the argument i
think you'll see that play out that was
definitely the argument i was coming so
we'll see how it shakes out
there was of course the baby boom
between seasons
some of these babies and their parents
are no longer on the show
they're not it's not addressed in the
first episode do you know if there are
conversations you had about where
your friends who are no longer on the
show are we acting like they're
voldemort and cannot be named that's the
thing i mean we spoke about them all of
the time because they're still a part of
our life and we definitely spoke about
people who are no longer going to be
around like at brittany's baby shower i
was so nervous to see stassi and lala
and like you know just like talking to
la la brittany's baby shower but i don't
know what will be left in it was
definitely a dress just because they are
such a big part of all of our real
lifestyle
right and it seems that some of those
relationships have grown because of
motherhood i mean you and stasi
hartford and summer are all hanging out
which is
nine years ago i don't think we would
have thought that would be the case um
what's it like to navigate those
friendships without the cameras around
is it easier
i think so actually yeah like stassi and
i i think we're probably the closest
we've ever been now and the babies and
going through you know giving birth and
labor and all of that definitely brought
us closer and being able to
talk to someone who's going through the
same thing or someone who's just been
through it and get advice from one
another has definitely brought us a lot
closer
do you know how they feel about no
longer being a part of the show are they
at peace with that or is it still like
maybe they have a little fomo
um
i think that's a question for them yeah
okay i'll take that answer we got a lot
of season to watch
is there anything you're very excited
for the viewers to experience that
you're like i cannot wait till this airs
our relationship honestly like i've
never been so excited to have a
relationship on this show because this
just feels
the most real of any i've ever had i
mean i know it is like this is my person
i finally i thought it was gonna be the
tv what i thought was me hanging a tv
you can do it in five you can do it in
okay it's coming to you
there is we do reference the seven
minute tv hanging in the premiere yeah
there's a lot this guy can do in under
seven minutes
making a baby with one of them
i was gonna say this is going somewhere
i know it is um on the flip side is
there anything you're dreading reliving
or anything the audience should be
bracing for impact for
all of the lala
drama um honestly because it was you
know we started off and we're like okay
we're gonna just move past all of this
and then
it takes a turn you know obviously it's
no secret that we're in a good place now
so it's just going to be hard
reliving all of that but just knowing
where we are i think it'll be very
interesting for people to see i don't
think it's like oh spoiler i don't want
to watch it because i know they're
friends now it's like but getting back
to where we are now was not an easy road
whatsoever
[Music]